toujours puisque avec laurent boussier
nous recevons maintenant notre invité
qui est monsieur serge dassault le
président de la société marcel dassault
aviation et breguet aviation cela alors
que le prototype de l'avion rafale
dernier né des avions de combat connaît
un grand succès et que la société marcel
dassault propose de construire six
prototypes du rafale la mise au point de
ce chasseur biréacteur pourrait être
opérationnel si tout va bien
en 1996 alors tout de suite monsieur
dassault merci d'être avec nous et
pourriez vous nous parler nous dire et
nous parle des caractéristiques de cet
avion rafale
et bien c'est l'avion qui représente
deux niveaux technologies le plus élevé
aujourd'hui que l'on connaisse dans
l'industrie aéronautique mondiale
de par sa structure des matériaux
composites et les matériaux nouveaux
de par ses commandes de vol commande est
entièrement par ordinateur électronique
on le voit elle oui on le voit rouler
avec ses moustaches ce canard qui sont
devant nous à décoller il est léger
relativement il est le plus léger de sa
catégorie et grâce justement
l'utilisation de ces matériaux
composites
il a deux réacteurs qui lui donne une
poussée totale de 15 tonnes ce que est
très appréciable par les pilotes ce
qu'on n'a jamais vus sur les modes
assault on n'avait qu'un seul réacteur
beaucoup moins puissant qui va durer
donc des performances de décollage
fantastique blanc alors cet avion a volé
pour la première fois il ya quinze jours
en moins il a un peu plus de quinze
jours il ya 17 jours exactement en moins
de quinze jours il a exploré une grande
partie de son domaine de vol les
pratiquement opérationnel maintenant il
va pouvoir partir à farnborough
comment peut-on faire maintenant en
quinze jours ce qu'on faisait il ya
quelques années à peine en trois quatre
cinq mois voir des fois une année
complète et bien c'est grâce à toute
l'expérience accumulée depuis des années
par les ingénieurs et les techniciens de
la société des avions marcel dassault
et puis aussi de toutes les sociétés qui
ont participé à la construction par q
pour les équipements nous avons
au fond réalisé sept avions avec
ordinateur avec des simulateurs
le pilote a fait une cinquantaine
d'heures de vol avant le premier vol sur
simulateur on a simulé toutes les
possibilités de fans pour vous les
trouvez et finalement quand on le fait
voler et bien cela que ça marche très
bien et on est très heureux on est un
petit peu de l'avenir voilà alors
monsieur dassault justement vos bas cet
avion technologiquement vous nous le
dites il est au point mais alors
maintenant qu'est ce qui va devenir qui
êtes intéressés par le rafale est bien
le rafale à un marché fantastique et la
marche est fantastique parce que il ya
dans le monde des centaines et même
quelques milliers d'avions qui vont être
remplacés dans une dizaine d'années dans
15 ans tu dans la temps ce sont les
directeurs actuellement en service dans
toutes les armées de l'air les fantômes
les f18 les tornado et puis les moulins
les acteurs tels que les f16 et même les
mirages qui devront être remplacés dans
une quinzaine d'années donc il a un
marché fantastique et seul de sa
catégorie
alors maintenant de manière pratique
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour lui
qu'elle qu'est ce qui va poser dans les
quelques années qui viennent combien
vont être construits qui valait
construire avec qu'il voulait construire
comment ça va se passer de manière
pratique et bien vous devriez demander
cela à monsieur le ministre de la
défense parce que il y a d'abord un
problème budgétaire un problème de choix
un problème d'argent problème de budget
et il faut que les décisions soient
prises par par le ministre assez
rapidement si l'on veut que cet avion
sera en service en 1996 on a parlé d'un
avion européen
un avion de combat européen bon alors on
sait que les allemands les anglais les
italiens les espagnols essaie également
de construire quelque chose mais qui
sont moins en avance que nous enfin que
le rafale est ce que vous pensez que le
rafale peut être un avion européen sire
que d'autres pays européens peuvent se
grouper ses sbires autour de lui et
parce qu' est-ce que c'est pas un peu
dans dangereux financièrement je veux
dire pour la france d'être la seule
nation en europe à avoir ce type d'avion
si jamais dangereux pour la france de
faire un avion
elle l'a fait depuis des années et les
mirage iii les f à linars et me dont il
a fait tout seul mais je crois que il y
a un potentiel de coopération non
seulement aux acteurs du mondial qui est
aussi extraordinaire pour cet avion
bon il y à l'autre groupe européen qui
aujourd'hui est orientée autour de
l'avion qu'on appelle le efa avec les
anglais les allemands les italiens
espagnols mais nous verrons plus tard
comment ça va se passer
et puis il ya les belges qui n'ont pas
pris de décisions qui sont assez
favorables notre avion ainsi que les
hollandais et les danois et la réaction
très rapide de la mise au point de cet
avion va permettre sans doute à beaucoup
de pays de se manifester de façon
favorable
nous avons déjà certains pays qui
veulent venir voir la juriste revoler
c'est formidable à l'extérieur de
l'europe même
oui bien sûr par exemple je peux pas
donner de jeu peuvent aider le pays mais
je peux vous dire que demain je vais à
istres avec deux pays différents et qui
n'ont rien d'européen
tu vas voir l'avion non pas pour le
commander évidemment enfin car elle
s'intéresse et il peut devenir l'objet
de coopération extrêmement large et non
pas pour le commander mais pour le
fabriquer avec vous est peut-être nous
aider à le financer je ne sais pas et à
toutes les possibilités
mais monsieur dassault est ce que vous
pensez que l'europe ne devrait avoir
qu'un seul avion de combat ou pourrait
en avoir plusieurs
la logique voudrait qu'il en ait quatre
grilles et canon non pourquoi et la
concurrence est excellente et puis les
deux avions peuvent être différents là
peut être associé à une mission à
l'autre et notre l'un peut être plus
gros le plus petit vous savez il faut
pas non plus avoir peur de fabriquer des
avions différents même en europe
regardez les états unis ils ont quatre
cinq six avions différents et peuvent le
faire et c'est très bien il ya un autre
problème aussi ses avions valent
vraiment de plus en plus cher les landes
combat valent maintenant des sommes
faramineuses est ce que vous pourriez
nord qui va pouvoir dans un an dans 10
ou 15 ans se payer ce type d'avion qui
sont technologiquement très avancés ils
valent très cher qui peut se les payer
vous avez eu à très cher il vaudra
peut-être il coûtera peut-être 20
maximum 25 % de plus que le mirage 2000n
j'aime beaucoup de clients il ya des
pays qui se sont rachetés des 18 qui
couche qui coûte très cher dans des f-15
et coûterait cher vous savez je n'ai pas
que la défense n'a pas de prix parce que
évidemment que l'avion seront chères
mois on en achète mais il ne faut pas
croire que c'était bon coûtera très cher
et au contraire par rapport à ses
qualités ses performances ont en port
c'est au rayon d'action finalement il
sera moins cher que de marge 2011 est un
président heureux je suis un président
heureux
oui parce que j'ai sur devaux cuvée
d'avion et une source formidable il à
monsieur dassault merci beaucoup d'être
venu de parler du rafale et à bientôt je
pense puisque sera pas là on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler beaucoup d'ici
à 1996 vous utiliserez a mis en service
depuis version merci